威張って戦争をするという事で
なんかすごく悲しかったんですね
誰かがいいと悪いということではなくて
どこかで一方的に人を殺していくんですね
だからこの時代 こんなに情報発達していて
いくらでも互いに話すことができて
それでも人間っていうのは人の話を聞こうともしないし
ただ戦ってやれば 殺してやれば
それで問題解決するだろうと思っているような感じなんですね
だから ソ連の大統領が言ったような感じで
なんか突然原始時代に戻ったのではないかと
いわゆる殺してやれば問題解決するんだと
脅してやれば問題を解決するんだと
自分の言うなりになってくれるんだという考え方はなくなってないんですね
だからそこでその人々がやっぱりアルベニア人を殺すことは良くないとということはいいわけに出すと
だからアルベニア人を殺されるのは良くないんだったら
コソボ人を殺しましょうという論理なんですね
そういうふうないろいろ言い訳して
こうやって人殺しになっちゃうと
昔より危ないんですね
昔よりも人類の生命は大変危険になってしまっちゃうんですね
なぜ昔より危ないかというと
今世界っていうのはそれほどバラバラでもないんですね
いろんなところでも固めているんですね
ですから 爆弾を落としたのはアメリカ軍隊かもしれませんけど
そこはNATOといういくつかの国々の同盟体としてやってるんだから
もしそれどんどん増えたならば
他の国々も参加しなくちゃいけないことになっちゃうんですね
だから どこかで小さな戦争でも起きたら
それは世界戦争まで広げる恐れは昔より随分今あるんですね
それからいくらでも人を殺されるぐらい能力を持ってるんですね
ですから 人間っていうのは本当にこれ進歩しているんですかと
という問題が出てくるんです
だから道具としていろんな新しい新しい道具を作ってるんですね
だから その道具を作ることは
我々は進歩だと 発展だと思っているんです
それで道具を作るんだったら
飛行機みたいな新幹線みたいなもの
道具を作るんだったら
まあそれほど悪いわけじゃないんです
例えば 手術にいろんなきめ細かい道具
今作って使ってるでしょうに
レーザー剣やらものすごい血管の中までもう潜り込んで
もう張ったり塗ったりすることもできるぐらい
それは大変ありがたいでしょうし
で 今いろいろ手術で 昔は胸を切ったり
お腹を切ったりした手術いくつか今は切らないで
ほんの小さな穴だけ開けて
その中から覗いてみて治療できるっていうぐらいの発展していて
そういう道具の発展っていうのは誰も良くないとは思わないんですね
でも それよりも発展しているのは人殺す道具なんですね
だから人殺す道具はいっぱい作って
自分たちの命をね そんなに危険にしている
それからそれ危険性っていうのは
このコロラド州でね 学校の子供がたくさん子供たちを殺したりとか
カナダでも同じことで
小学生が人を殺したりとか
それは武器のせいでしょうに
子供たちの頭の中に殺すのはごく普通なことで
かっこいいことやと そういう風に現代知識の世界で教えられているんじゃないんですか
その危険は 平和な国である日本もやっぱり汚染されているんですね
だから地球は一つに固めているんだから危ないんです
それはアメリカはみんな武器持ってるんだからしょうがないと
我々日本は安全だとは言い切れないんですね
人を殺すためにはピストルなくても何でもいいんだから
野球のバットでもいいんだから
ですから この日本でも小学生ぐらいの子供たちが何か犯罪を起こしたりする
そこはどういうことかと考えると
やっぱり頭がおかしくなってるんですね
おかしいというかどうか分かりませんだけど
やっぱり他人の痛み 他人を感じない
殺してもいいと 自分の楽しみなんですね
それは だからそれは危険ではないかなと
特に現代世界ではもう全部もうどんどん小さくなってくるんだから
この情報関係の世界が発達していくんだから
小さくなって固まっているのはいいことで
地球の人類はみんな それはいいことなんですけど
そのことと同時に何かどこかで進化していないところがあるんですね
原始的なところはそのままではもう相手を殺してもいいという気持ちはそのままです
ですから この道具だけ発展させるのは
まあ世間のことを見ると
それほどいいことではないんですね
それで子供が人を殺しちゃったんだから
武器の使用をコントロールしようとアメリカの議会で提案出されて
見事に却下されるんですね
それでみんな万歳までするんです
却下しましたと クリントンさんの考え方は同大という感じで
だから我々に道徳を教えようと思っている人々が何に反対しましたかというと
自由に武器を使うことは良くないというそれではなくて
自由に使ってもいいと
誰でも そういう意見でしょうに
賛成したのは だから人間が進化していないということ
人間は成長していないということは本当に情けないぐらいなんです
だからどこかで人を殺したりすると
なんかすごく悲しくなるんですね
それで我々のこのこの国に近い
北朝鮮にしたっても 話によると大変経済状態が悪くて
いろいろ経済的に問題があって
国民が苦しんでいるという話はありますけど
どっちか行ったことはないんだからわかりませんだけど
それは置いておいて もう国の全財産使って国の全財産絞って武器を作る
別に北朝鮮と韓国が仲が悪いんだからといって
北朝鮮か韓国の方がいきなり向こうに行って戦争しようというふうなことを思わないと思いますけど
韓国にも韓国なりのいろいろ問題がありますから
この経済状況はですか
日本と韓国と もうそこら辺
国々みんな今大変でしょうし
このバブルの問題は日本だけじゃなくて韓国にも入りましたから
だからそちらはそういうことで忙しくて大変暇がないんだからね
もう隣の国に行って戦争しようというね
そういう気持ちはないだろうと思いますけど
だからはっきり考えると
もう北朝鮮に誰かが敵がいるわけじゃないんです
それでもなんで国を挙げて国の全財産絞って
そういう武器なんか作ったりするんでしょうかと
だから核兵器作っているかないかっていうのも
疑いはものすごく書かれていて
頑固とそれは断って見せようとはしないとかね
だから見せようとしないということ自体がやっぱり疑わしいんですね
で パキスタンも核兵器作ったり
インドも作ったりとか
だから いかにこの人間の考え方はね
人間らしさが堕落していくかと堕落していくかというか
全く進化していないというか
どちらかなんですね  激しくしゃべるのは私の趣味だから
私に言えるのは もう人間はもう本当に 一歩も進んでないんだと
原始のまんまだと あの洞窟の中で生活した時代
そのまんまだと それで現代の方々はすごく怒って腹が立って反論するかもしれませんね
何言うんですか 我々はこんなに進んでいるんではないか
で 何を見せるかというと
自分作っている道具と武器を見せるんですね
他の何一つも見せてくれません
人間として立派なことを何かしましたと
そういうのを見せるものは何もないんです
ほんのちょっとのことでも腹が立って怒って立ち上がっちゃいますから
私はある日本当に怖くなったこともありますけど
この日本のことで この北朝鮮の問題でいろいろインテリという人々がまあお話ししているんですね
テレビで そういう人の話を聞くと
ものすごく怖くなったんですね
ものすごい凶暴なんですね
こんな原子爆弾でも作って
日本にももう放り出したらどうするんですかとかね
我々は憲法をすぐ変えるべきですよと
で 私たちもちゃんと準備しておいておかないとやられてしまいますよとかね
ああ 怖いと もしそういう話がほんのちょっとでもこの国で広げたならば
その考え方は それは怖いんじゃないんですか
日本は北朝鮮に対してももう立ち上がる姿勢をしているんだと
なぜならば もう北朝鮮の方々も韓国の方も
もうズルズルあっちこっちいっぱいいるでしょうに
そんな隠れて そんなことは隠れて
家の中であのご飯食べながら
もう北朝鮮のもう全部潰した方がいいと喋ったって
もうそれは家の中のことだから別に問題ないんだけど
でもそうやって公で喋ると
それはもうすごくその考え方を広げちゃうしね
あれはやっぱりこの この戦争の種ですか
火種は心にあるんだと
憲法は平和な憲法かもしれませんだけど
まあ一部の日本の方々の心の中でも
やっぱり戦いたい 潰してやりたいという
この戦争の火種があるんじゃないかなと思って怖くなったんですね
だからそうすると 連鎖連鎖反応で
もう世界はもう大変な危険な状態なんですね
それでまあ この戦いという概念についていろいろ考えてみて
何か人間としてもっといい言い方がないかなと
という話なんですね 今日は
平和的な生きる 生き 生きていられる
えーと 何か方法でもないかと
私たちはいろいろ意見を出すだけで
それは各自人間がそれは実行するかしないかということはまた別な話で
です  一番最初に言えるのは
まあ私はお釈迦様の言葉しか
あの 説法に内容としては使いませんので
ですから まあ一応 まず言えるのは
この武器の それから道具の進化より
とても人間に大事なのは
人間が必死になってやらなくてはならないのは心の発展でありますということなんですね
武器があってもなくても生きていられるでしょう
それから何でしょうか
あの道具とかね あってもなくても生きていられるんです
まあ道具あったら楽ですよと
道具なかったら まあちょっと苦しいですよということはありますけど
武器は何のためですか
武器があると自分の命は危険ですね
持つこと自体が だから今ももう思い存分
ソ連にしてもアメリカにしても
いっぱい核兵器と化学兵器とかいろんなものを作ってしまって
それは使うことをできなかったんですね
それもそちらに詳しいかもしれませんだけど
今どのように処分すればいいんですかと
もう処分する方法もないんですね
処分しようとしても その
あのゴミはね 大変な恐ろしいものなんですね
あの みんな問題にしているのは
この あの潜水艦ですか
原子力で動く 総理の先生がもう全部もうもう時時間になってもう全部使えないしまあまあ全部何て言いますか
解除して処分しなくちゃいけないんですけど
あれ原子力を使って原子力使っているんだから
なかなかそれはできなくて
そのまま放っておいているんですね
だから漏れているんでしょうし
海にも で それだけじゃないんですよ
同じ問題 アメリカでもあるんですね
言わないだけで ですから
武器を持っちゃうと まあ使わなくたってもそんなもんになってしまっちゃうんですね
まあそういうことで こういう世間的なことを私たちは言っても
もう誰も聞いてくれませんので
あの 私たちはこのお釈迦様もそれをよく知っていて
このまあ世間に説法したっても
ただ無駄話になるだけ
それよりは一人一人捕まって
それ一人一人に言えばどうですかと
これ一人一人の心の中で戦争は消えたら
まあその人が平和でしょうと
その方が実行しやすいんです
皆様方にも世界の戦争をなくそうということは
おそらく無理だと思います
で 例えば隣の国々が何か戦争をしようと思っちゃったら
一般の方々が行って反対してやめなさいと言っても
これは無理だと思いますけどね
聞いてくれないんだと
でも一つだけできることはあるんですね
自分が戦わないと 自分が争わないと
それは人間一人一人 一個のバイキンみたいなもんで
これをたくさん集めたら大変大きなもうバイ菌の塊になっちゃって攻撃するんです
ですから 一人一人の人が戦争戦いをしないならば
いいということなんです
まああの それから個人の話に入りますけど
個人個人では戦争は起こせません
まあそれはわかりやすい
でも問題はこの個人は戦争を起こしませんだけど
考えて考えていくと 国一つの場合も
最終的には決断を出すのは一人の人間なんですね
その最終的な結論を出す一人の人間が
いっぱいいる人々の意見を聞いて結論を出すと
ということになりますから
結局みんなの意見固まって一人の人の決断になっちゃうんですけど
それで周りにいる人々が戦いたいという気持ちがあると
この最終決断を出す人にとっては断れなくなっちゃうんですね
それでもう一つあります
この最終決断を出す人は一番力を持っているんですね
その人が戦いたい気持ちがあると
自分の議員たちやら大臣たちやら
そういう顧問の人々やら
他の人々を抑えるんですね
こうしましょうと 抑えちゃうと
まあ自分の大統領の意見だと
総理大臣の意見だということで
それはどのように通してあげればいいかと
みんな考えて結論作っちゃうんですね
ですから そういうところ
そのカラクリがあるんですね
ですから 例えばある国が任せた人が戦争をしたければ
周りの人々は戦争したくないとしても
その戦争したい偉い人がみんな抑えちゃうんですね
自分の考え方を抑えたら
その人々は自分の身の安全のために自分の職業を安定したいから
その人の意見に賛成する
そうすると この偉い人がやっぱりみんな同じ意見だから
じゃあやりましょうということになっちゃうんですね
[咳]そういうことで個人個人も戦争を起こすっていうことはあり得るんです
それでこの戦いっていうものはね
争いというものは 戦争だけじゃない
なぜ戦争に対して私はいっぱい喋ったんですかというと
この それは反対だと一般的にみんな思ってるんだからなんですね
戦争は反対だと まあそれでわかりやすいんですね
でも争いはそれだけじゃないんですね
どんな人間も いつでも本能として争いたいんですね
戦いたいんですね 他人を壊しちゃいんですよ
潰したいんですね あれ不思議なんですね
不思議でもないんだけど
まあどんな人間見ても戦いたい
争いたいという気持ちはあるんです
だから そのその人が自分生きてる環境の中でそれなりの争いをやってるんです
例えば家の奥さんが私は争いはしませんと
でも自分の息子が外へ遊びに行っちゃったら喧嘩するんだと
なんで私はしないのに息子がするんですか？というふうに疑問に思うかもしれません
でもそれは違うんです
息子が息子の世界で争いやっていて
お母さんがお母さんの世界で戦って争ってるんです
この争いの形が変わってるだけなんです
本当はみんな何かの形で争って戦って喧嘩しているんです
戦争は不幸を招くならば
大量の人を殺して大量の人に苦しみ悲しみ与えるならば
個人個人でやってる争いも確実に苦しみ悲しみを作るんです
だから本来我々は戦いたい
誰かを潰したいと 誰かにライバルを作って
その人をやっつけたいというふうに思っているんだから
我々はみんな苦しんでいるんです
戦う側も戦われる側も苦しみなんですね
だから自分が苦しみを作って
他人にまでその苦しみを広げてしまうんですね
ですから 一人で苦しんでいるのは
それは別な問題で この一人で苦しむことを苦しみながら
その苦しみを周りのみんなに広げてしまう
みんな苦しませる ですから
ものすごい醜い やってはいけないことなんですね
争いというのは  そういうことだから
この まあ争いはいっぱいたくさんありますからね
それ一つずつ言う必要はないだろうと思いますけどね
で いろんな形の競争あるんですね
で まあ例えば何かまあ
仕事をね インタビューあるとする
オーディションあるとする
それでまあまあ  10人参加したりも
選べるのは一人かもしれません
それは別に避けられないことで
必要なのは一人だけですから
一番いい人を選びたいんだと
それは選ぶ側の考え方だからね
それだけのことなんですけど
そちらにすごい苦しみが生れてくるんですね
この参加する人々 何で苦しみが生れてくるんですかというと
それは競争だから 人一人しか選べないんだよというぐらいのことを理解しておけば問題ないんだけど
この他の9人の人々はライバルだと
なんとかして倒さなくてはならないんだと
と思っちゃうと大変苦しいんですね
それは苦しみだけじゃなくて
いろいろ嫌味言ったり
何か一言葉言って相手をけなしたり
そういうことをするんでしょ
陰口を言ったりとかね
何かちょっと邪魔をしたりとか
ほんのちょっとの軽いイジメをしたりとか
それだけのことでものすごく火事のように苦しみが生まれてくるんです
やった人にもやられた人にも
やられた人は黙っていませんだからね
それも争いなんです それから
その中からいろんな不正的なことまでする
自分を選んでもらうために
もうどんな手段でも選ぶではないかと
そういうところまでいったりする
そこで結果として何が生まれてくるか
それすごい苦しみなんですね
もし一人が選ばれても
それを選ばれた人が不正的ないろんなからくりやったならば
それはあの他の九人は黙ってませんだからね
それを言いふらしたりして
また大変な苦しみが生まれてきます
まあとにかくもういろんな形で我々は戦う
舅さんと親御さんが戦う
子供と母親が喧嘩する
夫婦は喧嘩する 友達同士でものすごく喧嘩する
喧嘩戦いない社会はないんですね
時々このこういう人々もいるんですね
まあ他人とはものすごい認めたくない
喧嘩したいんだけど まあ喧嘩は口ではしませんだけど
まあみんなもうどうでもいい
けしからんない人々だと思って
自分が一人一人になると
私はそういう人々と関係ないんだということで一人になって
またそれで苦しいんですね
一人になってしまったら
単独行動するようになったら
それもよくあります 仲良くしないで
自分だけ単独行動しようと
よくないし苦しいんです
だから いろんな形で争いはあります
この嫉妬することもありますね
まあ嫉妬ということはまあ男性にもありますけど
女性の場合はかなり明確に見えるようにありますからね
あれはまあ口で喧嘩できないし
手で喧嘩できないんですね
その代わりにその争いっていうのは嫉妬として現れちゃうんですね
嫉妬すると 嫉妬すると苦しいんじゃないんですかね
すごい苦しいんです 仲良くすることができなくなっちゃうんですね
平和がなくなっちゃう
そこで自分だけ苦しんでいて
嫉妬すると どんどん苦しみが増えると
それはもう他人にもまいてしまう
分けてしまう 仲間作ったりする
嫉妬の仲間とかね 増えちゃうんですね
で それから問題っていうのは
やっぱりこのわずかなところからもういろんな争いが生まれてきて
人間の生き方はね すごく苦しい生き方になってしまって
これなかなかもう抜けられない
大変なことになっているんです
もし誰かがこのもう争いの気持ちをね
なくすようにしてあげれば
もう一撃にして世の中っていうのはすごく楽しい
楽な世界になるんです
この私たち思うほど この生きるということは難しいことではありません
人間というのはもうただ単にもう生きるだけのことなんですけど
それはできなくて もう大変なもうもう罪責を自分の背負っているような感じで
大変なことだと思っているんですね
よく見ると まあ仕事をするわ
家に帰るわ 家でそれなりに生きているわ
まあ家にいる人々は家を守るわとか
子供たちは学校に行くとかね
まあそれぐらいのことでしょうに
病気になったら病院に行くとかね
給料が足らないんだったら
まあどこかへバイトにでも行って
もうちょっといくらか収入をもらうとかね
人生っていうのはそれぐらいの単純なものなんです
[背景音楽]スーパーに買い物に行って
今日の買い物を今日はどんなもの料理作るかと思って
それ相応品物を買って家に持ってきて
それ料理作るとかね それ終わったら洗濯物あるんだったら洗濯をすると
家にお客さんが来たらお茶を出して
いかがでしょうかとお話をして
それも帰してあげると
他の何かありますか？旦那さんが仕事に行ったら
それはそこで仕事をすることだけ
仕事っていうのはそんな複雑でもうやりにくいとんでもないことじゃないんですよ
その日 例えばどんなエンジニアにしたっても
複雑なものを設計する人にしたっても
その人のプロの世界だからね
それはその人の趣味でもあって楽しみでもあるんですから
これ何もわからない私に何か機械でも設計しなさいと言ったら
これ私にはできませんだけどね
設計する人にとっては
それは自分毎日やっていることだから
そんな難しいことじゃないんです
私に人の心臓手術でもしなさいと言っちゃったら
人を殺すしかできませんよ
でも外科にとっては これもう日常茶飯事で何のこともないんです
おもちゃおもちゃ作るような感じで
おもちゃの組み立てのような感じでできるんですよ
その人々に ですから 別に苦しい
どこで苦しいんでしょうかね
生きることは どこで大変ですかね
よく考えてみてみると
もうなんかすごくなんかクールな心で考えてみると
もう生きるっていうことは
まあいとも簡単なことであるはずなんです
国の総理大臣になったって
そんな難しくはないんですよ
何か大変な問題ができたりする
だから決断する人々でしょう
政治家になるのは だから
この場合はこうしますよと決断するのは
その人々の仕事だから
いとも簡単にできるはずなんです
自分に決断できないと思ったっても
法律というものはあるし
いろいろ情報というものはあるし
そういう専門家がそれをずっと調べるんだからね
調べてそういう答えですよと言ってくれるんだから
そんな難しくはないんです
あるいは例えば総理大臣
何かに情報収集必要になって
何か決断したいと でもわからないんだと言ったら
その人々に命令するで
あんた方はちゃんと調べなさいと
その人々はその世界なプロだから
徹夜して全部調べてくる
見たところで気に入らなかったら
もうこれダメですよと
もっとやりなさいと言えばそれだけのことでしょうに
ですから よく考えると
これ普通の家庭で主婦やってる人には
明日からあんた総理大臣やってくださいって言ったら
それはもう無理なんです
そんなこと世の中で全然ありえないんです
ですから 我々の日常生活っていうのは
我々はどんな立場でいようとも
アメリカの大統領であろうが
どこかの住むところなくて
川のそばにテントを張って住んでいるホームレスな人であろうが
生きるということはそんなに難しいことではないんです
でも 人間にとってはこれこそ大変な問題なんです
病気になっちゃうんですね
血圧が上がる 心臓発作を起こす
幼児虐待までする 殺人までする
生きるために 自殺もする
最後に できなくて失敗して
だからどこかでおかしいんです
どこかの金融関係の人が
それ専門家でしょうに
プロでしょうに 小さい時からそういう方向で勉強して
仕事ものすごく身についているすごいプロでしょうに
なんでつまらない失敗して自殺するんですかね
そこで人間の生き方はおかしいということは見えるはずなんです
何がおかしいか この争いなんですよ
戦いたくなる 誰かを潰したくなる
そこでプロは必ず失敗する
医者たちの中でも争いが生まれるんです
あの人より私の方が研究上手ですよと
争い気持ちが生まれたらものすごい苦しいんです
そこでもしかすると余計なことまでするかもしれません
法律で認めてない治療をする可能性あります
自分の研究として そういうことで問題が起こったりして
その医者が自殺することで終わっちゃうんです
だから争いさえやめれば
なんか随分簡単 楽なんですよ
生きるということは 争いさえなくなってしまえば
ものすごい余裕が出てくるんです
人生に この余裕というものがないと
ものすごく性格的に人間っていうのは燃えちゃうんですね
燃えるっていうのは いい意味で燃えることではなくて
悪い意味で 本当に火がついたような感じで
燃えてしまうんです だからもう早くも髪の毛が落ちるか白くなるか
で 早くも内臓がもうガタガタになるんでしょう
で 人間の体っていうのはかなり頑固なもので
これ九十歳 百歳になってもそんなに病気になるんじゃないんです
時々調べてください 九十歳で
百歳で 元気で元気で 畑の仕事をするわ
もう社交ダンス会に行くわとかね
毎日十キロぐらいもう散歩するか
あるいは四キロぐらいジョギングするとかね
そういう老人の方々は日本にいくらでもいるでしょうに
なんでその人々にだけいい心臓がついていて
我々に悪い心臓がついてるんですか？なんでその人々にだけいい腎臓がついてて
我々の腎臓が悪いんですかと
そんなことはないんです
そういう人々の性格を見ると
ものすごく気楽で 明るくて
敵がなくて 倒したい人がないんです
ただ楽しくいるだけ よし
朝だよ じゃあ散歩に行くぞと
で 帰ってきたら もう奥さんがご飯作ってるんだったら
それをもう美味しく食べると
ですから 元気で健康的で長生きすることは
人間にはどんな人間にも可能なんです
生まれつき精神 体が病気っていうのは
それは病気な人々だからね
それは分かりやすいことで
それは誰も問題にしない
本人さえも 生まれつきいろいろ故障して生まれる人々は
本人さえも問題にしない
それは例外であって そうでないどんな人間にも
まあすごく明るく元気で長生きすることはできるんです
健康的で そこで日本の場合は
もう実際に長生きできる人々がたくさんいるんです
それは幸せかというと
なんかそれはすごい社会問題なんです
年寄りが老人人口が増えるんだと
大変だと これからどうしようかと
あれさえも問題に見ているんですね
もう年金はもらわないんだと
これからの若い人々はとか
保険制度はもうどこかでやめなくちゃいけないんだとか
なんか悪いみたいです
長生きするのは だったら最初から言ってくれればいいのにね
最初からもう言ってくれればいいし
もうとにかくいろんな食べ物やら薬やら
長生きできるようなものをいっぱい作ったりして
あんた長生きするのは迷惑ですよと
なんでそれ迷惑になるんですかね？なんで老人人口が増えることは迷惑になるんですかね
私は言いたいのは ずっと争い現象があるんだからなんです
老人人口が増えるということは
老人のせいなんです まず子供を作ってないんです
いっぱい いっぱい子供を作ってないんだから
もう一人しか作ってないんだから
あるいは二人しか それで二人に対して四人老人がいるんだから
四人かな もっといるんですね
だからそれ一つの問題
じゃあなぜ子供一人か二人しか作らないかというと
争わなくちゃいけないんですよ
戦わなくてはいかないんですね
だから この争いで負けないぐらいで
一人 二人だけ作る 時々一人作ったことも
自分が戦争に負けるんだと思って一人も作らない人もいるんです
だからそちらにもあるのはそういう現象なんですね
別に生まれてくるんだったら
まあ生まれてもいいんじゃないんですかね
で 若い人々がいっぱい出てると若い人がいっぱい仕事をするでしょうに
そこで政治システム 経済システムを作る人々も
誰かと戦うことはそこに基本的にあるんですね
誰かを倒すこと 経済学っていうのは競争の論理に成り立っているんですね
だから誰かが倒して自分が儲かるという論理なんですね
そういう論理で考えるんだから
老人人口が増えちゃうとそちらはお金使うだけですよと
儲かってこないんだと
だから迷惑ですよと 正直なことはそれなんです
それ言った方がいいのに
正直じゃない嘘をつくんですね
年取ったらもう薬ばっかり飲んで
もう仕事もしないでいるんだから迷惑ですよと
そう 本当はそういう気持ちなんですね
で そこで人間に生きる権利ないんですよ
この地球に生まれた人間が自然に死ぬまで生きる権利があると思いますけど
それはないんです 経済のおかげで
ただ儲かってあげなきゃ生きる権利はないんだと
じゃあ何のために 誰のために儲かってるんですかね
そこは考えてないんです
ただ人を倒すためなんです
誰かを この国際経済的な問題でいろいろ問題
トラブルいっぱいあるでしょ
あれも争いなんです アメリカは日本に文句を言えば
日本もいろいろ裁判を起こしたり
いろんなことをするわ
もう韓国もこの間テレビで聞いたんだけど
この韓国ではいっぱい外車があるんだけど
いいえ 逆に言ったんですね
日本の車は世界中どこにでも輸入できますけど
輸出できますけど たった一つの国には輸出できませんと
どういう国かといったら韓国なんです
ですから この そうやっていろいろトラブルがある
なんでトラブルを起こすかと
これは人間愛する経済ではないんです
例えば日本の立場から考えれば
日本で作るものはもう片っ端から輸出して
いっぱいお金入ればそれだけで十分だと
そちらは関係ないんだと
もし売れないんだったら
何かダンピングでもして売れるようにすると
そこでダンピングするという問題では
アメリカ以外日本に文句を言う力強い人々はいないんだから
アメリカは平気でそれに文句を言って
もう戦ったりする だからこの戦いなんですね
じゃあアメリカがいっぱい金儲かるんだということによって
アメリカの国民ぐらいでも幸せありますかね
ないでしょうに ホームレスはいるんだから
学校に行けない人もいるんだから
学校に行ったこともない人々もいるんだから
あの国に もう正しい統計やら計算させないだけで
ちゃんとやってみると
この貧しい国々と大した変わりはないと思いますけど
字が読めない人とかね
治療 薬買うお金がなくて
お医者さんのところに行けなくて死ぬ人がいますよ
そちらも ですから あれ
何のための経済豊かさなんですかね
何のために世界大国になるんですかね
日本にしたって日本も経済大国でしょうに
ほんのちょっとのこと変わっちゃったら
もうみんなクビになってしまっちゃう
食べるものなくなってしまっちゃう
ずっといきなりホームレスの人々サーッと増えたでしょうに
今それは強引に追い出されてもうないように見せかけている
ですから この経済の世界でも
人々は大事なことを忘れているんです
これは人間のためやと
幸せのためですよと 幸福のためにやってるんだと
誰かを殺すためにやってるんじゃないんだと
だから戦いっていうのはいろんな面であります
それでも経済的に 政治的に
政治の世界にしたっても
世界中も政治家のこの競争
争い 戦いっていうのはあまりにも醜いでしょうし
皆様はあまり興味ないんだから知らないでしょう
おそらく いろんな国々でもやってること
日本でも結構やってるだろうと思いますけど
政治家の間では ちょっとでも優しい人なんかは
ちょっと一日いただけでも気持ち悪くなって
もう逃げたくなるほど恐ろしいんですよ
政治家さえも平気で人を殺したりする
殺す  自分で殺すんじゃなくて
もう殺させるんですよ
だから ある人が党を作って民主主義やとか民主主義ですよと言って
それで他の党はみんなライバルで
とにかくあることもないこともなんだかんだ言って
その他の党を全部倒そうとしている
倒せないとからくりでもして
何かクーデターでもクーデターと言えないね
まあまあ 英語だったらクーだけなんですけど
まあいろいろそうやってからくりでも何かでもして
そちらを倒すそうではないかと
だからインドネシアで選挙もやっと始めて
党もう400 500ぐらいかな
出てきて大変な争いで
そこで一人の女性の方がなんとなくたくさんもらうようになってきているんだから
で 彼女を倒さなくちゃいけないんです
それで戦争に負ける人々が
それでまた宗教を持ってきて
彼女は正しいイスラム教じゃないんだと
頭は被ってないんだと
普通の服で人の前に出てなんだと
だからもう大統領になる権利がないと
なんか言うんですね キリスト教の人々と仲良くしすぎだと
だったらイスラム教だけの人々が政権取っちゃったら
またキリスト教あれ他の宗教を信じている人々
みんな差別されてもう追い出されるでしょうに
だから何のためですかと
わかってないんです 政治やっているのは
ただみんな動物みたいに犬猫みたいにお互いに戦っているだけ
世の中 それはもう子供の学校から考えて
人は死ぬまでバカみたく意味もなく目的もなく戦っていくんですね
バカ見たことは言いたくないんです
失礼だから 完全なバカなんです
正しいこと言わないと失礼だと仏教で言うんです
だから一体全体この人類は何をやってるんですかと
そこで明確に見えるのは
この無知という ただ単に生きている
とにかくあっちこっちにものを壊すと
あの男の子たちが小さい時
性格あるでしょ あれあれは子供だから可愛いんだけどね
ただこうやって歩きながら何かあったら足で蹴っ飛ばしちゃう
もうちょっと音でも出す空き缶でも何かあの缶の蓋でも瓶の蓋でも何でもいいんです
見たら一回一回蹴飛ばしちゃったら
これ音を出して飛ぶでしょうに
それでまた面白くなって
また蹴っ飛ばしちゃう
また蹴飛ばしちゃうと
それでもう次 隣の家の中にそれ飛んでいくかもしれません
それやべえ 逃げようとして逃げたりもする
子供たちはそんなことやってるともう結局まあまあ可愛いんですけど
まあ昔どっかに散歩していると
ちっちゃな男の子がもうお母さんは先に行くんだけど
後ろから行くんですけど
そこら辺でこのフェンスがあったんです
網の鉄でできている これ見たら
この子におそらくすごい眼光に怪獣に見えたでしょうと思いますけど
言ってあれ足で蹴っ飛ばすんですね
まあフェンスは何のことも
まあ子供だからね 何のもう曲がることも何もなかったんだけど
2 3回ぐらいよく偉そうにこのスーパーマンじゃなくて
日本でなんて言いましたっけ？ウルトラマンの格好をして
あれ蹴っ飛ばしてもう行っちゃったんだけどね
あの性格は死ぬまで男も女もみんな持ってるんだから
無意味に戦う そこな問題は
無意味に戦う で 結婚しちゃったらもうとにかくもう決まってるんです
姑さんとはやり合わなくちゃいけないんだと
だからそういう風にずっと昔からもう暗示かけられて教えられてるんだから
周典もさんももう誰かもはっきりわからない人なのに
もう戦おうとする 向こうもあまり相手のことを知らないくせに
もうやり合ったりする
戦う以前 お互いに理解すること必要でしょうに
互いに それから戦うならば
何のために戦うかと その目的をはっきりするべきでしょう
それだったらすぐ戦いは終わりますけどね
そういうこともなく ただ必死になってみんな死ぬまで競争競争
戦い戦いと そういうことで
基本的には人間っていうのは物事を理解しようとしない
物事を理解しようとしない
ずっと暗示かけられているように暗示かけられていますから
マインドコントロールされているんだから
まあその通りに動いている
原始時代の人々は戦ってきたんだから
そのマインドコントロールで次の世代が生まれて
で 今までなってるんです
だから現代社会の人類にも
もう前の時代からもう戦いのマインドコントロールが入っちゃって
ただ戦うだけ で それで子供は戦いますけど
あれは子供には必要なことなんですね
手と足と もうそれはちょっと訓練しておかないといけないんだから
生きるためには だからいろいろ小さないろんなちょっとした戦いとかね
怪獣と戦うとかね 怪獣はいないんだから
そこにあるフェンスでもいいんだから
それにちょっと電信柱でもいいし
それにちょっと人もう足で蹴っ飛ばしてみるとかね
電信柱怪我するわけでもないし
子供は怪我するわけでもないし
それでも終わりますからね
でもそれ以外 我々はもう戦わなくてはならないとマインドコントロールされて
そのまんま生きてるんですね
そこで戦いを争いをやめるために必要なのは
いつでも我々は一つ考えてほしいんですね
私は何のためにこれをやってるんですかと
私の目的は何ですか？と
それで目的は何ですか？とマインドコントロールされている人に聞いても答えが出てこないんです
あなた方の人生の目的は何ですか？と人に聞いてみてください
あるわけないんです 誰にでも
だからおかしくてしょうがないんですよ
聞いたらわからないんです
はっきり言って目的はありませんと言うならば
それも一つの考え方なんですけど
なんかうわごとを言うんですね
だって生きていた 生きて生まれたんだからしょうがないだろうとかね
あるいはもう生きることは大変ありがたいことでしょうとかね
あるいはもう親からもらった大事な命だからとかね
何もらったんです 親からは
生まれる以前自分がいなかったんだから
何もらうことはないでしょうに
もうなんとかうわごとを言うんですね
そういうことでマインドコントロールされているんだから
何のために生きているんですか？と聞いても答えが出てこないんですね
ですから この仏教ではマインドコントロールまたは他のマインドコントロールでしか治りませんだからね
一つ答えを出しているんです
幸せになれと 平和になれと
楽に死なさい 幸せになれ
平和になれ 楽に生きなさいと
他の言葉に入れ替えると苦しみを捨てろと
苦しいことをなくせと
苛立ち 落ち着きないことを
なくしなさいと そこはもうモットーにすれば
例えばなんで仕事をするんですか？と聞いたら
ちゃんとご飯食べて 食食べて
ちゃんとそれなりの家に住んで
家族と仲良くしたいんだから
子供たちにも苦労しないで楽々に成長してほしいんだと
それにはお金が必要ですよと
それに仕事をしているんだ
そこを入れ替えた方がいいと思います
仕事をするのは尊いですよと
会社は神様ですよとかね
そういう余計な考え方を置いておいて
で 家族に収入を持っていかなくちゃいけないんだと
家族を養わなくちゃいけない
それで楽しいと 家族のみんなもう苦労なしに元気ですくすくと育てて
奥さんも大変満足そうな顔をしていると
それは楽しいと そうやって一つ一つ明確にクリアにした方が
戦いは消えると思います
それで楽に生きること
幸せにいること 苦しみをなくすこと
気楽に せっかく生きているんだから
じゃあ気楽にしましょうと
せっかく生きているんだから
もう戦うことをやめましょうと
そういうことで そういうことを頭に入れて
この過去のマインドコントロールを捨てなくちゃいけないんですね
それで戦いは消えるはずなんです
例えば 隣の奥さんとずっとやり合っているんだと
こちらの奥さんが これちょっと待ってと
こんなことずっと隣の奥さんとやり合っちゃったら
私はこの家でずっと生活しなくちゃいけないし
そちらもその家ずっと生活しなくちゃいけないし
これで毎日毎日苦しいでしょうにと
顔を合わせるたびに何か嫌味一つ言いたくなりますから
向こう側からも言われるんだから
それで楽しいんですかね？それで幸せですかね
だったらちょっと待ってと
私はなんで 1 日でも苦しまなくちゃいけないかと
私は楽しく気楽に軽々く生きていたいんだと
死ぬまで だったらもうあの隣の奥さんとやり合うことはあまり意味がないんだと
そちらはそちらでそちらの生き方で生きているのではないかと
なんで私はそちらにおせっかい言うんですかと
ということで 平和が出来上がっちゃうんですね
戦いは消えちゃうんですね
だからいつでも我々はこの人間には
やっぱり生きる場合は幸せに生きることを目的にしなくちゃいけない
軽く生きることは目的にしなくてはならないんですね
それでその そう ちょっと間違わなくてはならないところもいろいろありますね
時々人が言うんですよ
金いっぱいあって お金がいっぱいあると
豪邸に住まれる 住ま住むことはできると
ああ それこそ幸せだと
だから時に宗教の世界では平気でそういうことを言うんですね
だからこういうこういうお祈りやら信仰やら
そういう特定の呪文やら
そういうことをやってくださいと
わざと違う目的を作っちゃうんですね
その中で何が生まれるかというと
また競争が生まれるんですね
また戦いが生まれてくるんです
金持ちになってやると
それは目的にしてはいけません
豊かになってやると いえ
気楽に平和で生きているんだと
金持ちになろうと思ったら
自分の平和が崩れるんだったら
心の安らぎがなくなるんだったら
家庭はバラバラになるんだったらやめた方がいいんです
家庭まで子供まで犠牲にして
何のために豊かになるんですかね
豊かといってもこの財産増えることをするんですかね
それは意味がないんですね
だから 金を愛することは
人を愛することに変えなくちゃならないんです
だからこの大事なのは
人は幸せで生きていることですよと
そういう風に変えると
戦いはかなり減るだろうと思います
だから人生の生きることのモットーは
やっぱり他人を愛することなんですね
どうすれば相手を憎いと思わないで可愛いと思えるかと
どうすればみんなのことを親切に感じられますかと
どうすればどんな人のことも自分のことのように心配することができるんですかと
だから私はそのまあ言うだけじゃなくて
このコソボの戦争の場合はね
やっぱりコソボ人の苦しみも
アルベニア人の怒りと憎しみと
その苦しみも すごく悲しく感じるんですよ
どちらも悪いんだけど
はっきり言うと 戦争を起こすように
苦しい状況に陥れるように
最初に行動を起こしたのはアルベニア人なんですけど
そちらは別にしたい あなた方と一緒に行きたくないと言って戦い始めて
テロを始めて いろいろと
もう向こうも腹が立って
もうお互いに双方もめげない民族だからね
でやり合ったんでしょうし
だからお互いにもやっぱり
あ いいですよということは言えない
いろいろ条件があるんですね
コソボを離したくないという気持ちは
向こうにもあって こちらにもあって
こちらはたくさん住んでるんだから
向こうの場合は歴史的な自分のいろいろあるんだと
この国は自分の心臓だと
セルビア人の だったら仲良くすればいいでしょうに
セルビア人の文化的な
歴史的な 大変大事なところだから
どうぞ あなた方は自由にしてくださいと
協力しますよと言ったら
別にそこで戦いないでしょうに
問題は我々は苦しむことじゃないんだと
何でお互いに殺し合いしなくちゃいけないんですかと
殺し合いして そんな国一つ取ったって意味がないでしょうに
永久的に民族 2つがお互いににらみ合って自慢するだけで幸せですかね
だからセルビア人のお祭りにも
もうアルベニア人も呼んで
みんなでね もう肩を並んで手をつないでお祭りやるとか
アルベニア人イスラム教だからそちらのお祭りも行って参加してとか
仲良くするとか もういとも簡単ですよ
そんなことは 戦うよりは
殺してやろう 殺してやれということをよりはね
だからもう無知でしょうに
余計なことを考えちゃうんです
どうでもいいこと そういうことで
仏教 お釈迦様が言うのは
この智慧を作ってくださいと
物事を理解しなさいと
この価値があるかないかと見なさいと
ある一つの土地のために
ぶった切ってずっと殺し合いやる
それで一部は勝ちますよ
戦争だから 勝ったっても
永久的にあの人類に恨まれるでしょうに
人類っていうのは それから子供作ったり
子供孫作ったりするんだから
ずっと孫までひ孫までこの憎しみ続けるでしょう
それで価値があるんですかね
ある土地のために戦って勝ったそうと
だから今我々は死ぬまでしか生きてられません
だからその間で我々仲良くしちゃったら
我々の子供たちは当然もうそんな差別を知らなくなっちゃうでしょうに
だからあまりにも人間のこのアホらしさがあって
もうだから完全な無知ということなんですね
何かくだらんことに戦うんですね
それに私はこの子供の頃
子供に教えてもらったストーリーがあるんです
それ単なるこの面白い笑いための笑うためのストーリーですけど
日本語に訳せばそんなに笑えませんだけどね
あればこの国の言葉で言うと
なんとなくおかしい おかしくて楽しいだけのストーリーで
この鬼 2人がいて この鬼 2人がずっと長い間
あまりにも仲良くしているんだと
すごく仲がいい これ 100年
200年  300年じゃなくて
もう千年で鬼だからね
あまりにも長い間仲良くして仲良くして
一人の鬼が他の人々の生き方を見たらね
みんな互いに戦っているんじゃないかと
喧嘩しているんではないかと
思い浮かんだんです あ
みんな喧嘩しているんだと
やっぱり我々 2人がおかしいと
喧嘩しないんだから じゃあ喧嘩しようよと
だからみんな戦ってるんだから
この鬼が やっぱりあれは面白いかもしれませんと思ったんですね
そうしたら 自分の友達にも
じゃあ二人で喧嘩しようよと言ったら
ああそうね じゃあ喧嘩しましょうと
向こうが言ったらそうですね
じゃあどうやって喧嘩しますかねと
だからお互いにもう納得したんだから
喧嘩することをね じゃあ喧嘩しましょう
喧嘩できないんですよ
それでも それこれ喧嘩研究した鬼が分かったんだよ
喧嘩の原因は 分かって
じゃあいい方法ありますと
私は一つ石一つ持ってきて
これは私の石だと言います
そうするとあなたは いえ
違いますよ これは私のものやと言いなさい
それで喧嘩できますよと
ああそう じゃあやりましょうと言って
そのもう一人の鬼が石一つ小さな小石一つ持ってきて
あんた知ってんの？この石は私の石だよ
あ そう じゃあいいよ 別にいいですよ
もらっても それでもうダメやと
この人喧嘩できないんだから
こういう人で喧嘩できないんだ
ダメやと これで喧嘩できなくなったんだと
それ子供が作ったストーリーなんですけど
かなり鋭いことを言ってるんです
人間の競争もなんかそんなもんなんです
この土地は私のものだと
これは私のものだと そうやったらもう喧嘩するんですね
子供の喧嘩もそうでしょうに
これは私の椅子ですよと
いて兄弟で喧嘩する 子供は頭が悪いんだから
例えば男が私の椅子ですよと言ったら
女の子がお母ちゃんにお母ちゃんもうと言って文句を言うんですね
椅子に座らせてくれませんと
お母ちゃんももう喧嘩の塊だから子供に怒るんですね
椅子をあげなさいと それは男の子から見たら
別になんであげる必要あるんですかと
自分が座ってるんだから
自分の椅子に自分座ってるところで
それを追い出しちゃって他の人を座れる
座れるということは意味がないんですね
子供の中に怒りと戦いの気持ちが生まれちゃうんですね
そうやってつまらないことから戦うことが生まれてくる
これは私のものやと思っちゃうと喧嘩が生まれるんです
これは私のもの 私の国
私の民族 私の宗教とか言ってみんなやってるでしょうに
一つの宗教を信仰する人々は
他の宗教を信仰する人々を殺しちゃう
よくやること だから宗教を信仰しているということは
宗教の中身はなんですかというと
まあ平和であるし みんな愛することであるし
もうすごいことを言うんですね
言って 言いながら他人を殺すこと
どこまで頭が悪いかと
で よく情報知っているのはキリスト教の世界なんですけど
あるキリスト教の宗派のパンフレットやらなんだか読んでみると
まあ絶対的な神でいて
愛だ愛は全部みんな神はみんなにみんなを愛していて
我々もそれは実践しなくちゃいけないし
それは正しく相手が実践していないんだと
あの連中は神を侮辱しているんだと
神を否定しているんだと
アンティクリストだと
サタンのもう何がら そうやって言ってもう倒そうとしてるんです
だからいい加減にしなさいと
自分が幸せと平和と愛を言ってるんだったら
それ実践しなさいよと
相手は何を信仰したってもいいんじゃないんですか
自由だったら だから宗教の世界でもいつでも殺し合い
殺し合い 殺し合いでなくても戦い
競争 憎しみっていうのは限りなくあるんです
だから仏教から言えば
国のために戦うことも全く無意味なんです
国のために戦って何か得るんですか？というと
ただその国の人々が死ぬだけでしょうに
時々人はこう言うんです
自分は別にそういう財産はなくなってもいいんだけど
やっぱりこれから生まれてくる子供たちに何か残しておかなくちゃいけないんだと
だから戦うんだと それで私が言いたいのは
だったらあんたは子孫を作らないでくださいと
なぜならば その人はこれから生まれてくる子孫のために自分の人生を台無しにするんだから
戦って殺し合いで 作らなきゃいいでしょうに
それだったら だからやっぱり後から生まれてくる人の問題は
そちらの人々は自分で見るんであって
我々は平和な社会を作って
お互いに全く戦わない
調和がある幸せな社会を作っちゃうと
我々の子どもたちも戦いっていうことはどういうことかと分からなくなっちゃうんです
で 随分時間喋りましたから
皆さんは疲れているような顔をしますので
ちょっと 10 分ぐらい休憩いたします
では 始まります これから厳密に経典のところから喋ります
お釈迦様の時代であるお坊さんのグループが喧嘩したんですね
仏教ではこれは厳密に決まり違反なんです
お釈迦様はいつでも言うのはこの出家者にサマッガサンモーダマーナ
アウィワダマーナ キーローデキーブータという言葉をいくつか使っているんです
いつでもサマッガ 平和で仲良くアウィワダマーナ
お互いに言い合ったりしないで
論争しないで ムクンローカ
人が何か言おうとすると
あ 何でしょうかというふうな聞きたい気持ちでいること
人の意見 考え方 何でしょうかみたいな考え方
あ 何ですかって そんな感じでムクンローカを見ながらという
人の それからキーローデキーブータといったと
それは分かりやすい 牛乳と水のようにと
だから牛乳は全く違うもの
水は全く違うものだけど
一緒に入れちゃったらさっぱりわからなくなっちゃうんです
すごい違う 2つでしょ？牛乳と水は
全く違う 2つですけど
牛乳の中に水を入れちゃえばどちらか分からなくなってうまく溶けること
そのように人間が生活するべきですよと
人間と言ったら お釈迦様は人間にじゃなくて
自分の弟子たちが だから個人個人で牛乳のような人と水のような人がいるかもしれませんだけど
個人個人ではいろいろ意見があるかもしれません
生き方違うかもしれませんだけど
それでも一緒になって仲良く一緒になってくださいということだから
全くいかなる理由があっても
争論 論争すること 戦いことは禁止なんです
人をけなすこと それからいろんな暴力は全くダメなんです
暴力というよりも 手でぶつかる
ぶつかることだけじゃないんですよ
精神的な暴力はいっぱいありますからね
超能力の暴力もいっぱいありますからね
私には特別な力があるんだから
あんた気をつけなさいと言っちゃったら
それさえ暴力なんです
私はちゃんと修行している聖者だからね
聖者にそんなこと言っちゃったら
あなたひどい目に遭いますよと言った途端
それ暴力なんです あるいはもう何て言いますか
祟りをかけますとかね
そういうあって 精神的な暴力もいっぱいあります
それはいかなる暴力ももう禁止なんです
で まあそう言っても やっぱり人間というのは
まあもう言うこと聞かないんだから
もうあるお坊さんたちのグループがもう喧嘩しちゃったんですね
で お釈迦様はただ一言言葉
喧嘩やめなさい あなた方は不幸になるんだ
言って帰るんです で それでも喧嘩やめないんですね
また喧嘩する で 私は喧嘩するように何か言ったんですかと
教え 私の教えを見なさいと
私の教えをあなた方は理解するならば
そういうふうに喧嘩になるはずがないんだと
いい加減にやめなさい
何回も言っても聞かない
それでお釈迦様はどうしましたか？というと
そう自由に喧嘩してくださいということは言わなかったんだけど
誰にも言わないでひそかに出て行っちゃったんです
どれほどそんな喧嘩にお釈迦様は反対かというと
すべて仏教 お釈迦様の教えでしょうに
自分の弟子たちでしょうに
自分が始めた宗教でしょうに
全部捨てて一人で逃げて出て行ったんです
喧嘩するんだったら 自分の弟子たちも教えも全部もういいんですよと
全く一人で山の中に入って
森の真ん中に入って 全く一人で生活していたんです
人間に顔を合わせないと
だから その上でわかりますよ
このいかに戦いは良くないかということ
戦いになるならば 全て捨てて捨ててもいいんです
お釈迦様はその場合 捨てたものも並のものじゃないんですよ
自分作ったシステム 自分が長い間修行して悟って
その悟りをみんなに教えていたんだから
それで大勢の人々も悟っていて
国のもう国 3つ  4つ 周りの国
国 全部仏教徒になってまでして
その教えを教えた人は全て捨てて出ていったんです
理由は 弟子たちが競争というか
戦いを始めたんです それも別に手で殴ったり
喧嘩したりすることではなかったんです
ある意見が意見違いで
お互いに別れたんです
ただそれだけのことなんです
その意見違いで分かれたところで
お互いにもめない いえ
私たちの立場正しい 向こういえ
私たち言っていることは正しいんだと
そうやってどんどんどんどんこれバイキンだから戦いっていうのは信者さんまで広げていって
国の人々もそれぞれもう派閥作っちゃって
こちら側かこちら側かと
でお釈迦様 じゃあ私はやめますということで
そのやめますと一言葉も言わなかったんです
なぜかというと じゃあ私はやめますと言ったら
それ脅しでしょ 暴力でしょ
お釈迦様出て行っちゃったら困りますよということで
暴力だから それも言わないで
朝起きてみるとお釈迦様いない
ただそれだけ どこに行ったか誰もわからない
3ヶ月とか 森の真ん中で生活していた
そこで面白いことに その森の中で一人で生活していたこのゾウ一頭がいて
まあまあ どうせ一人で生活しているんだから
オスですからね オスのゾウ一頭がいて
お釈迦様とこのゾウがすごく仲良くなったんです
それで森の中でこの2人でもう野生のゾウですけど
2人で仲良く生活していたと
お釈迦様 お前もさ 一人で寂しいだろうとかね
ゾウもそれなりにお釈迦様の色々面倒見たんだというふうにストーリーはありますけど
そこはどこまでどうかと分かりませんだけど
ゾウがお釈迦様にお湯でも沸かしてくれたんだとかね
いろいろ森の中で火がありますからね
それで石を温めて転がってきて
水たまりにそれボーンと入れたところで水が温かくなったとかね
それは作ったストーリーかもしれませんだけど
とにかくゾウ一頭とは仲良くしたことは
もうこれ結構経典に出ているんだから
これだけは確かなんですね
そこで托鉢に出られないんですよ
もう森の真ん中だから
それでゾウがあっちこっちから拾ってきたものは召し上がった可能性はあります
それぐらいこの戦いにお釈迦様は違う意見を持ってるんですね
意味がないんだと ほんのわずかな戦いにも意味がないんだと
そこでそれについてお釈迦様はたくさん説法しているし
これはあまりにも量が多いんだからね
私にはさささっと言えませんだけど
一つだけ物語は言います
お釈迦様はおとぎ話を一つ言ったんです
昔々 あるススメの群れがいたんだと
ものすごい大きな群れで
そこである狩人がいて
毎日網を持っていて どこかで餌をまいて隠れているんだと
それでそこで餌のところに鳥たちが止まったら
網をかけて捕まっちゃうんだと
捕まってそれを売って生活しているんだと
食料として そこでこのどんどん数が少なくなると
このススメのリーダーがこう言うんですね
なんか私たちは餌を探そうすると
我々の餌場にこういう狩人が来て
我々捕まって殺しちゃうんだと
これで大変だと 私たちは何か逃げる方法ないんですかと
ありますよと 我々はみんな今までバラバラではなくて
みんな徹底的に仲良くしましょうと
みんな一斉に一人のように仲良くしましょうと
そうすると餌を食べている時は
あの人が網をかけると
網をかけたらみんな一斉にせーのと言って飛びましょうと
一人には網をかけませんだけど
みんなで翼を叩くと もう何のことなく降りてくるんだと
はい 分かりましたと みんな一斉に固まって餌を食べる時はまた網をかけられたと
網をかけられたら みんなこのリーダーが号令を言うんだから
はい せーのと言ったら
日本風にもう鳥たちが翼を叩く
そこでもう飛んでいったと
網と一緒に 飛んでいって
大きなこの木の上にみんな止まると
止まったら下から出ていかれるんですね
狩人見たらびっくりして
みんな網と一緒に逃げちゃったんだから
追っていって追っていったら
木の上に網がかかったまんまで
それ取り出すのは大変で
一日かかったそうです
今みたいなビニールの網じゃないんだからね
破れちゃうでしょうに
ですから 一日かかって夜遅くなって
もうヘタヘタで何も獲物はない
家に帰ると奥さんにも怒られるんですね
何も持ってこないとどうやって生活できますかと言ったら
今日は大変な変なことになっちゃった
ということで その日は食べ物はないと
次の日も捕まってくるぞと言ったら
次の日も同じことなんです
そこで二日 三日何も獲物を持ってこないと
奥さんがなんかちょっとこの人怪しいんだと
他のところ誰かできてるんではないかと
あんたもう獲物を取って
その他の誰かにあげているんではないかと言って
またすごいこちらで喧嘩になっちゃうんですね
それであまりにどういうこと言うと
この狩人がこう言うんですね
あんたちょっと待ちなさいと
今はあの鳥たちは平和でいるんだと
仲がいいんだと 互いに喧嘩しないんだと
でもそんなことはすぐいつかそいつら喧嘩するんだと
その日で私はみんな捕まって殺してあなたに食べさせますと
ちょっと待ちなさいと
言ったら まあその通りに
そのススメたちの一匹の一羽のススメが下りようとすると
他のススメの体にぶつかったんだそうです
それで それは物語だからね
なんで私の体にぶつかるんだ
私を踏むんですかと言ったら
まあそこで別に私はわざと踏んだわけじゃないんですよと
ただ私はもう空から降りるんだから
スピードコントロールできないでしょうしね
だから私は降りる時はあなたそこにいただけのことでしょうと
そんな失礼なこと言って
この二人は喧嘩する それでこの二羽が喧嘩すると
どんどんどんどん他の鳥もいきなりその反動でいろいろお互いに喧嘩始めて
そこでリーダーが喧嘩やめなさい
喧嘩やめなさいと なんで喧嘩するんですかと言っても聞かない
そこでみんな鳥たちもあっち向いてという感じで
喧嘩はやめたんだけど
仲良くはしない あっち向いてるんです
そこでどうせ餌場に行ったら網をかけられた
網をかけられたら一斉にはい
飛びましょうと言ったら
お前先に飛べよ なんで私が先に飛ばなくちゃいけないかと
お互いにキャーキャーと言ってるんだそうです
そう言ってる間で 狩人が全部鳥たちを捕まえて持って行って
みんな死んじゃったと
だからそれは簡単な子供に分かりやすくしているストーリーなんですね
だからほんのわずかな喧嘩もみんなの破滅にいったと
だからわざとあの喧嘩もつまらない喧嘩にしているんです
下鳥一羽が止まってて
上からザーッと来た もう仲間だからザーッと入り込んじゃうでしょうに
だから自分の家に子供なんか入る場合はものすごい失礼でしょうに
もう靴はあっち捨てて
一つはこっち捨てて カバンはあっち捨てて
もういい加減でしょうに
言ってもうソファがあったら
それにいきなり飛び飛び込むし
それも壊れるし だからそれは自分の家で自分もあれだから
もう気持ちよくやってることなんですね
ですから そういう感じで向こう仲間だからサーッと降りたんです
そこでもう一羽がいて
そちらにちょっとぶつかっただけのことなんですね
それでなんだお前はということで喧嘩になって
ただそんなつまらないことなんです
結果としてはみんな死んでしまったと
そういうことだから たとえつまらないことでも
喧嘩にはならないようにしないと
大きなことに喧嘩するどころか
ほんのちょっともつまらないことでも
言い争いにならないように
すごい厳密に人間が気をつけるべきですよという話なんです
そのストーリーは ほんのわずかなことでも
どこまでこれ燃えてしまうかと火事になるかとはわからないです
それは一応仏教の考え方なんですね
[背景音楽]それからこのジャイナ教という教えがありまして
そのジャイナ教の教祖様が亡くなったんです
お釈迦様より年上なんです
で 亡くなったら その教祖様の弟子たちが一気になり喧嘩を始めたんです
何に喧嘩始めたんですかというと
この教えに対してそれぞれ専門家ができていて
私たちはこういうこういうことだよ
あなた方はこういうこと
違いますよと言って あなたは全く真面目に勉強していない
私は勉強しているんだと
あんた言うことはちゃんと先生の考え方に合わないんだと
そうやって互いにものすごく喧嘩し始めたんです
お釈迦様は喧嘩大嫌いだから
お釈迦様その現象を見てね
お坊さんたちには あなた方にはあの宗教の宗教団体見えますかと
どうですかと 自分の教祖様の教えについて
みんな今ものすごく仲が悪くて喧嘩しているんだと
それでその場でも二つに分けちゃったんです
その場で でも私はあなた方には争論
喧嘩できないように 誤解
誤解釈ならないようにきちんと教えているんだと意味を
そこは絶対私は知っている
あなたは知らないということではやってはいけません
この教えはいかなる理由があっても
相手と戦うために使ってはいけません
論争するためのものじゃないんだ
それは心の安らぎを味わうための実践方法であって
真理も道も教えているんだと
だから実践しなさいと
その時点では 仏教という宗教は自分の特色を言ってるんですね
例えば 神は本当に信仰しているのは私たちだよと
あの人々の神の信仰はガタガタいい加減ですよ
だから潰せということではないんです
だから自分の神様が慈悲を教えているんだったら
相手が慈悲を実践していない
じゃあだから殺せではというのおかしいんです
自分の神様が慈悲を実践しないんだったら
慈悲を実践すればいいんです
そこを他の宗教でやってないんです
いつでも他宗教では他の他人
自分以外宗教はもう潰そうとしている
馬鹿にしている ですから
お釈迦様の場合は 自分がお釈迦様の道を理解できたならば
あの人をやってないんだからとかね
それは無意味なんです
私は嘘をつかないんだけど
あの人嘘をつくんだから
やっぱりどうしようかと
どうしようもいる関係ないでしょうに
だから嘘をつかないとかね
殺生しないとかね そういうことにいつでも私に来る問題で
そういうことで まあ殺生しないと言ったっても
みんなやってるんだからと
私はいえ それはみんなのことで
あなたは殺生しないようにしなさいと言っているだけですよと
全然それ理解しないんですね
私は殺生しなくても やっぱりもうあの人はこうやっていて
この人こうやっていて
これぐらい生命は殺されているのではないかとか
とにかく他人に これ喧嘩なんですね
それだったらキリスト教と何の変わりはない
他の宗教と何の変わりもない
それだったら仏教も だから人は殺生しようが嘘をつこうかね
その人と喧嘩するために教えじゃないんです
それはその人の生き方で
その人の理解のレベルであって
その人を殺生したならば
その人は地獄に落ちるんであって
その人を嘘をつくんだったら
その人は不幸になるんであって
私がいてその人に暴力を振るう必要ないでしょうに
だから自分が殺生しないと
自分が嘘をつかないと
自分が邪ない行為をしないと
自分が慈しみを実践しているんだと
慈しみを実践したって悪い人に対してどうしますかと
この間アメリカから話しかけてきた人がずっとその話ばっかしで
あの自分たちがLOVEというものは愛ですか
実践しているんだと はい
ということで いきなり私に聞くのはこのHATE憎しみの問題なんですね
そこで私の意見聞いちゃったら
まああなた方は神様に言われたんだからLOVEを実践しているんだけど
我々は自分が神がいようがいなかろうが
生命は互いにすべての生命はすべての微生物まで
すべての生命に対して愛を実践しているんだと
まあ上手にできるかないか別として
そういう理想で頑張っているんだと
まあ書く時はね 丁寧に書かなくちゃいけないんだけどね
自分が完璧にやるっていうことではなくて
やっぱり我々の教えはそういう教えですよと
言ったら あなた方はもうHATEということを認めないんです
で いきなり答えを認めませんと
言ったらもう世の中のこの悪いことやら人々をやっている
どんな悪い人でも あなたはもうその人にも愛をするそうですよと
その通りですよ たとえ殺人者であろうか
殺戮者であろうか なんで私はその人を憎んで殺さなくちゃいけないんですかね
憎しんじゃったら私は苦しいんでしょうし
そこは戦いの世界でしょ
自分の心を磨こうとしないで
他人に説教をするとする
それでまあ私はもうそちらの話をちょっと直せちゃって
あなた方は英語の使い方悪いんだと言っても
このなんでハエという言葉を使いますかと
言葉間違ってるんだと
あなたはこの悪いことは認めないと
自分の意見を言った方が良かったのにと
で 私は書いたのは I disagree
という言葉を使った方が良かったのに
I hate という言葉は間違いと
なぜならば この場合はハエとはそんな大した意味がないんだけど
でもハエっていうのはもう他のところで使ってみればとんでもない恐ろしいことだと
向こうは理解しないんですね
理解しないのは当たり前ですけどね
それで私は説明したんです
こういう風に 人を愛するんだけど
人を愛するということは
その人のバカげたことをすべて認めるということじゃないんだと
それを明確にしなさいと
たとえ殺人者には愛をあげる
あげるんだからって その人は平気で人を殺すことを認めるわけじゃないんです
だから人に対して親切なんですけど
人がやってる一切の行動を認めましょうと
そこは違うでしょうに
そこら辺でも我々の知恵はしっかりしていないんです
人間 誰でも正しいわけじゃないし
それから正しい人を愛しますと
何の意味もないでしょうに
正しい人 清らかな人だったら平気で向こうそう言ったんです
人々は正しくて生活するならば
まあ私はもう愛できますけど
悪いことをする人々にとっては
聖書に基づいてできませんと
私は書いたのはそんなことどんな犬猫にもできますと平気でこちらで言うことはそのまま英語で書いた書いたんです
親切な人に愛することは犬猫もやってますから
何のおしゃれにもなりませんと
犬猫もそうでしょうね
餌があげて頭なでてなでてやると尻尾振ってくれるんだから
だから正しい人だったら愛します
正しくない人だったら潰してやりますっていうのは
何の宗教的な精神的な育てでもないんです
だからみんなことごとく
一切 すべて平等に 無差別に
何の線引きもしないで
みんな生命だから慈しみを広げますと
そういうふうにみんなの行動
生き方 考え方を認めるわけじゃないんです
それで その場合 あなたの考え方は間違ってますよと
その考え方にはちょっと納得いきませんだけど
それくらいのことでしょうに
だからといって あなたは憎いわけじゃないんです
あなたは大事な人で 私にとってあなたも幸せで幸福で長生きしてほしいんだと
それを完璧に願っているんだと
この考え方の場合は それはちょっと認めませんと
それぐらいのことでしょうに
私はたちのやり方というのは
人が何か間違いを起こしちゃったら
間違いを直すんじゃなくて
人を潰すんですね そういう悪い刺激でずっと生きてるんです
それからなぜ人は戦いかと
戦争するかと 戦いの戦争の原因はお釈迦様
その場合はお坊さんたちの喧嘩の場合は 6つ言ってます
これ 1番目 コーデノウパナーリ
コーデノウっていうのはすっごい怒る
怒りっぽいということ
ウパナーヒっていうのは
なんですか 怒ってもすぐ冷めないんですね
これ持ち続くんですね
考えては怒る また考えては怒る
また考えて怒るという
このなかなかもう心から消えないんですね
あの性格を何と言いますかね
え？何でしたっけ ん？しつこく怒るっていうことじゃない
なんか違う 執念深い え？執念？あ
執念深いと で これずっと怒って続くんですね
1年でも2年でも10年でも40年でも
その性格 ある人がいるんだけど
パッと怒ってすぐ消える
もうすぐ忘れると 例えば子供たちの怒りはそういう怒りでしょうに
ものすごく怒って泣いたり喚いたりするんだけど
瞬時にもうあれはあっけらかんと忘れて
また笑ったりする その二つ
それで限界になるんですからね
そこでこの怒ると それから怒ったことはずっと忘れないで覚えておくとどうなるかというと
人間 こちらの教典によると
人間というのは道徳を忘れるんだと
人を愛することを忘れるんだと
尊敬するべき人は尊敬しませんと
こちらではブッダに対しても大変失礼なことをするんだと
教えに対しても失礼なことをするんだと
仲間 修行者に対しても随分失礼なことをする
だから怒ったらそうやって我々はものすごくおかしくなったんだよ
なるんですね 例えば 誰かの偉い人がいる
普通だったら我々は何も言いません
で なんとかであって その人に対してものすごく怒ったりする
怒ったら平気で悪口を言うんですね
時々 日本の方々は何かに反対する場合はね
議員さんやら大臣さんやら
もうどわーに行ったらもう面と向かって言いたい放題悪口言ったりもするでしょ
普段だったらその人々は立派な方々で
尊敬に値する人々なんですね
怒ってない場合は先生先生と言いながら大変丁寧に話したりするなのに
怒ってしまえばいきなりもう人間というのは動物になってしまっちゃうんですね
そこで怒りっぽくなったら
自分でやらなくちゃいけないことは一つもやらないんですね
自分でも仕事は全部もうやらないで
もう置いておいちゃうでしょうに
怒りに覆われちゃったら
ですから もう動物になっちゃうんです
その二つ 一番目の そこでこの喧嘩の場合は私が怒って喧嘩になる
相手が怒っても喧嘩になるということはありますし
ですから私が怒らなくても
相手が怒って喧嘩を売るということもあるでしょうし
だからまあ 売った喧嘩をもう買ってやろうということに
売られた喧嘩 そういうふうに人間なっちゃいますけど
ですから こちらで原因は内なる原因
外なる原因 2つありますね
自分の心の中に生まれる怒りは内なる怒りで
相手方が怒ってしまえば
それは外なる怒りなんですね
それ両方理解してください
両方理解して 早くも怒り消す
消すようにしなさいと
だから別に原因とかそんなものはごく普通
簡単簡単単純ですよ 生きる上で起きる問題だから大したことじゃないんです
その問題はなぜ複雑になるかというと
この怒りを消さないんですね
例えば旦那さんがちょっと遅くなって家に帰ったら
それは問題解決するのはとても簡単なんです
それに怒るでしょうね
怒るだけじゃなくて忘れられませんね
執念深くということで
そうすると大変な問題にそれ広がるんですね
だから一番やらなくてはならないのは
この原因は何ですか？とかなぜということじゃなくて
自分の怒りをまずなくしちゃうと怒りなくしちゃえば
あの問題というのはとても簡単なことで
ですから 内なる原因であろうと
外なる原因であろうが
先にこの原因をなくせと
原因はお釈迦様が言うのを
例えばあのユーゴスラビアの戦争っていうのは
アルベニア人とあのサラビア人の民族問題じゃないんですよ
原因はそちらにある心に
この高慢とわがままと憎しみと怒り
それなんですね だからアルベニア人住むべきかコソボ人に住むべきかということは
いとも簡単に解決できるんです
そんなことはそんな難しくないんです
先に直してほしいのは
この心の中にある相手を憎しむ気持ちなんだから
それでアルバニアに戻ってるでしょうに
戻ってきたら そちらのコソボ人もみんな片っ端からまた殺すでしょ
それで問題は解決しません
それをもう国際的には認めてるんで
そんな簡単には問題解決しませんと
だったら何のために爆弾を落としたと聞きたくなるんだけどね
それわかってるんだったら
だから問題っていうのは心にあって
コソボっていう国にあるわけじゃないんです
うん そういうふうに問題解決しましょうと
次の言葉は マッキーバランスというセットなんですね
マッキーというのは マッキーっていうのは他人のことを認めない性格
他人をバカにしたがる性格
他人が何かすごい立派なことをしたら
すぐそれにケチをつける
何のこともないんだと
それぐらいのこととかね
すごくこの自分以外の人々のことを認めたくない
すっごい醜い性格なんです
とにかくなんとかケチつけようとしている
国民的にも時々あるもんなんですね
自分の誰かが勝ったら
スポーツでまあすごく褒めること褒めること
もうもうあるものもないものも言いながら
そこで他の誰かがもう勝って自分が負けちゃったら
もうできるだけそれにケチをつけると
ということは大体国民的にも時々そういうマッキーというものは見えるんです
だからどんな人間にもあります
それはとても良くない
醜い 汚いんですね 大体個人個人によっても
私たちは自分の周りにいる人々が何かいいことをしたら
まあそれをなんとかケチをつける
なんとかそれの価値をできるだけダウンにする
あるいは何か探して探してでもその人を倒そうとしている
バランスというのはそちらの反対
反対の行動 反対のこういうこと
自分のことをすごくもう大きく大きく大きくして見せる
ちょっとつまらないことをしたっても
ものすごく言って言いふらして言いふらして
どうだいどうだい 私はこういうことをやってるんだとかね
言いたくなること だから自分のない徳をできるだけ広げようとしている
他人にある徳をできるだけ消そうとしている
それだったらまあ戦いになるでしょうに
時々兄弟喧嘩の場合もそういうことはあり得るんですよ
兄弟同士で一人が何かいいことをしたら
もう何か立派な褒めるべきことをしちゃったら
次の日はなんだそんなことってもう貶したりする
すると喧嘩になっちゃうんです
だから兄弟の間でも 夫婦間でも
友達の間でも そういうのは機能して喧嘩になるんですね
だから我々は逆に自分の徳をもう隠しておくと
あるいは謙虚になる 他人のいいとこは全部ちゃんと認めて褒めてあげるとすぐ仲良くなるんです
だから よく人のいいことをよくよく見て
見抜いて 見抜いて理解する人々っていうのは
かなり多く 大勢の人々の間で人気者になるんです
だから他人のことを言う場合は
その人のいいところだけ言っちゃえばいいんです
自分の頭でもいいところしか見えないんだったら
自分がすごく幸せなんです
バカに見えるかもしれませんだけど
本人にとっては幸せなんです
まあ昨日かな あるちょっと女の子が向こう側から来て
私はまあ見ただけで まあちょっと精神的に弱い人だなと分かったんですね
で あれは生まれつき障害で
で  うん そうやって来るんだけど
すっごい顔いくつでもニコニコニコニコニコニコ
だからもう周りはどうであろうか
本人はニコニコニコニコと笑いながら歩いてくる
こうやって歩いてくるんです
その瞬間で私は考えたのは
この子は幸せだなと だから他の人から見れば精神的に弱くて障害者と思うかもしれません
だけど体では別になんのことなく立派な女の子でしたけどね
体だけ見ると でもあのニコニコと見ると
人間の苦しみなんかは知らないと
嫉妬なんかはないだろうと
あの人はこういうことで悪いんだ
あの人はやばいとか そういう感覚がないんだから
なんのことなく笑えるんですね
なぜならば 彼女にとってはもしかすると周りの人々やらみんな親切に
弱い人だからね 親切にいい顔しか見せませんし
だからそちらの勉強もそれだけみんないい人だと
だからいいことしか見えます
だからニコニコだから
他の知らない人にしたっても悪いことをできませんよ
あっち行きなさいとかね
何やってるんだとか言えないんですよ
笑ってるんだから ですから
まあそういう風にならなくたって
やっぱり我々にも人のいいところをすぐ見に行くことできるんだったら
本当に幸せなんです 心の中で
だからその性格はなくしてほしい
そういう性格があると
必ずしもやることは悪いんですね
他人の徳を消そうとしてるんだから
やること悪いんです 戦争でよくあることでしょうに
戦争起きたら敵軍の悪いことばっかり言うんです
そんなに完全たる悪人がいるわけじゃないんです
自分たちのことを褒めて褒めて嘘ばっかり言う
だから日本でも戦争した時は
まあ日本軍隊ほど世界で一番強くて
どこへ行っても敵はことごとく倒すんだと
負けるってことは絶対ありえないと
よくよく言っていたんだから
そこで敵軍っていうのはもう悪魔そのものでということで
でもそんなことはありえないし
世の中 でも戦争になったら
そういうマッキーパラシーということは堂々と使う
だから かすかな競争でも戦いでも絶対良くないんです
すぐ醜い人間になってしまうんです
3番目 で  Iです  6番目はちょっと長い
6番目は取り立てます
一応ここまで簡単に説明します
イッスキーマッチェリー
イッスキーっていうのは嫉妬すること
だからもう他人に対して嫉妬する
そうすると仲良くすることはできません
嫉妬するのは他人のいいことなんですね
だから 自分と比べて他人が何かちょっと何かいいことがあったら
それですごく嫉妬して
自分がすごく暗くなっちゃうんですね
嫉妬しただけで自分が負けちゃうんですね
例えば 隣の人が自分より綺麗やと思っちゃったら
自分が嫉妬しちゃう それだけで自分がもっと醜くなっちゃうんです
体顔色が悪くなっちゃうんです
だから嫉妬する場合は同じ能力で嫉妬するんです
例えば 私は算数が上手だったら
もう一人の人が来て その人見たら私より算数が上手だと
だったらその場合は嫉妬するんですね
その人に対しては だから同じ能力で嫉妬が起こるんです
いわゆる同じ仲間の間に
能力が同じということは仲間なんです
そこで嫉妬が起こる 嫉妬が起こったらどうなるかと
自分の能力はもっと下がっちゃうんです
上に行くわけじゃないんです
ですから 嫉妬すると必ず喧嘩になる
善悪判断できなくなる
マッチェリーっていうのは逆に自分の能力自分だけのものにする
人に分けてあげたくない
ケチですね 物惜しみですね
物惜しみのことでも喧嘩になる
子供の問題にしたっても同じことでしょうに
あげませんと あのパレスチナ人とユダヤ人の戦争は何ですかね
パレスチナ人の土地をユダヤ人が取って
あげませんと だから他人の自分のものは全く分けてあげませんと
水さえあげませんよ パレスチナ人に
全部自分たち一人で取って
もう戦争して もう土地を自分で取って
もう配れません だから砂漠の中でどうやって生活するかと
だから それでも物惜しみが出てきたら
当然もう喧嘩することになっちゃう
ですから そこですぐこの物惜しみじゃなくて
みんなで分けましょうということになったら
何のことなく平和が出てくるんですね
で サトーマーヤービ サトーっていうのは
このクラフティという英語で言うこのずるいということなんです
する何かずるいことを悪いことをするという
なんとなく賢そうに見えます
だからするがしこいという言葉もありますけどね
賢そうなんですけど やることはなんか変なことを何かからくりいつでもやったりする
そういう人は相手に対して慈しみがないんです
こう言えば向こうは騙されますよと
もうこの日ではなくて
この日で言って こうこう言っちゃえばいいんですよと
そうやってこのずるいことばっかりするが
しこいことばっかり考えて行動したりすると
ものすごい嫌な人になっちゃうし
他人と喧嘩になってしまっちゃう
その人々も道徳なくなっちゃう
マーヤービっていうのはほとんど似ていて
ごまかし屋マジシャンみたいにもうごまかしちゃう
騙しちゃう マーヤーの辞書の意味は幻覚ということだからね
だから幻覚屋さんって言ったら意味がないんだけど
一応もう騙し屋ですね
で 悪い品物を売りたい
売りたい売りたい場合でも
大変ブランドの服を着て
大変なもう立派な高価なネクタイを着て
立派なカバンを持って紳士らしく家に訪ねたら
奥さんがやっぱりその人を信仰して
まあそんな立派な方だからと言ってすぐ買っちゃうでしょうね
そういうのがマーヤービなんですね
そうやって喧嘩に それも喧嘩の原因になります
争いの原因になります
正直でいいとということなんです
5番目パーピッチョミッチャーディッティ
パーピッチョっていうのはこの悪意というか
この気持ちがいつでも悪いことばっかり考えているんですね
例えば ある国が世界一になりたかったら
それはすごい悪い気持ちなんですね
なんで世界一にならなくちゃいけないんですかね
平等になればいいのに
私は日本一になりたいとかね
それだけものすごい気持ち悪いんですよ
日本一にならなくてもいいんです
普通でいいんですけど
そこでこのいろんな悪いし
私は必ず総理大臣になってやるぞと
だったらもう手段選ばないでいろんな方法でやっちゃうんですね
だから能力あればもうなれるもんだよと
そこまで頑張りましょうと言ったら
もう能力あれば正しい人はそのところになっちゃうし
それで世の中でものすごく悪いことばっかり考えるヤクザみたいに
この何て言いますか お金貸すいろいろ商売もあるでしょ
悪いことしか考えてない
その人にお金を貸してあげれば
どうしても返して返れませんと
だから他のところに貸してあげて
また他のところから貸してあげて
その人は完璧にダメにしちゃうんですね
そうやってもう悪いことばっかりやる人々
パーピッチョ ミッチャーディッティっていうのは考え方おかしい
この現代時々見えるんですね
私は神様ですよと平気で言う人々がいるんだから
だったら何で人間でいるんですか？と
なんで人間で苦労しているんですか？と
あんた神だったらなんで誰もあなたのことバカ以外誰も信じないんですか？と
と聞きそうにはなりますけどね
よくいるんです あっちこっち神様たちが
その神様たちを でも唯一の神様で世界を創った神様なんですね
なんで人間の間に紛れ込んでいるんですかね
自分で作った人間の間に
言うこともいい加減で
で もう一人最近あの世界救う人間が自分ですよと言い張り言ってますけどね
アルマゲドンが出てきたら
まあそうやってミッチャーディッティ悪い考え方
それからそうではなくて
そんなことではなくて
例えば戦うべきですよと
国を守るべきですよと
国のためならもう人を死んだってもいいんじゃないかとかね
そういうのも邪見ミッチャーディッティ邪見ミッチャーディッティ邪見なんですね
パーピッチョってのはするがしこいこと
ミッチャーディッティというのは邪見
邪見も喧嘩の原因になります
それで 6番目 まあ 6番目はもう皆様にもおそらく見覚えあるかもしれませんだけど
こういうのなくたって
こっちはパーリ語としてはちょっと長いんです
長いんだけど 簡単な日本語あるでしょうね
なんかファイターとかジェンガとかあったね
サンディッティ・パラマーシ・アーダハナッガーヒ・ドゥッパティ・ニッサーキ
これも本当はつ２つにした方がいいんです
サンディッティ・パラマーシっていうのは適当な日本語の言葉は私分かりませんだけど
説明はいたします 自分の意見というもの
徹底的にもう捕まってるんですね
これはもういろいろありますよ
家のお母さんから もうおばあさんから
もう自分の意見だから
もう頑固絶対変えないと
それで子供が不幸になる場合あるでしょうね
あなたはこういう家を当て続けなくちゃいけないんだと
子供が他の仕事をしたい場合はね
ものすごい頑固 それで子供亡くなっちゃうでしょうね
結局は そうやって自分の意見は絶対もう見直そうとしない
まあそれはもうそれとその
私はそう考えてるんだからと
もうそれ厳密に自分の意見を捕まっていること
全然見直そうともしないという
人の意見は絶対聞きませんと
というものすごい頑固であること
番目はアーダハナッガーヒ・ドゥッパティ・ニッサーキ
それはもう一人人間がいるんです
逆に人の話をそのまんま鵜呑みにする
あ そうですか じゃあやりましょう
あ そうですか じゃあやりましょうと
あ そうですか じゃあ信じましょうと
なんか逆に何ですか 自分というのは全くないような状態で
すっごい暗示しやすいというか
マインドコントロールしやすいというか
あのオウム真理教のあの人々みたいに
いまだにもう我々の尊者と言っても呪文唱えないからもう殺人者なんですけど
もうあっちこっち頑張れ
かわいそうに感じますけど
私は怒りは感じませんだけど
顔を見ると本当にかわいそうにかわいそうで
その人々がね だからこのアーダハナッガーヒ・ドゥッパティ
アーダハナッガーヒというのは
すぐもう人のこと言われたこと
すぐもうもう受け取ったと乗ったぞと
寸時にもう自分の意見というのはない
ドゥッパティ・ニッサーキでそれまた間違って受け取ると
だからこれも人類の性格なんですね
ある人々は頑固で 人の話は全く聞かない
逆にある人々は全く根性というのは何もない
もう言われる通りにはいはいはいはいはいと
で 例えば絶対的な神を信仰する人々が求めているのはこの番目の性格なんですね
言われる通りにしなさいと
反論するなと 神は絶対的だから信仰しなさいと
だけど 世の中にはそういう根性弱い人々の方が多いんだから
そういう風に この強引に言うものをそのまま鵜呑みにする人々の方が多いんですけど
自分の意見はいくら言っても間違ってる
絶対聞かんという頑固な性格はこちらに左側に書いてると
そのつも喧嘩の種になる
そのつあったら人々はやっぱり何やる？自分の意見に頑固になったら喧嘩でしょ？結局は
そこで自分の意見何もなくて
人を言う通りにやるやるなんか泥みたいな性格だったら
何やるかものすごい完璧に操れるでしょ
だからこのリーダーが言うことを何でもやると
それでいかに世界で戦争までやるでしょうね
このテロ活動とかね これ誰かがリーダーがもう言ってもう言っちゃうと
みんなまとめて人殺しに行く
イスラム教のハマスとかいろいろあるでしょうね
あれもこの番目の性格なんです
誰かが悪人がもう人殺し屋が
もう我々は厳密に原理主義で神を信じなくちゃいけない
だからみんな殺さなくちゃいけないということで
バカどもっていうのは
誰を殺してること同じ宗教を信仰してる人を殺してるんです
だからその三つの六つの性格は心にある
それある限りは戦いは治らないんですね
その六つも結局いいものじゃないんですよ
心にあったらもう苦しくて苦しくて気持ち悪くて
頑固な人に聞いても あなた頑固でいいんですかと
本当は恥ずかしいんです
あれは あなたは頑固だから何ものも見えない
本当にバカになってるんではないかと言ったら
それはもう認めたくないんですけど
結局頑固なんですね まあそれはそれで
これはこれですよで言っちゃうんです
だから我々の一般的な経験から見ても
ある人が何か意見を持っていて
その意見は間違っていると自分が思うと
それにその人にこれは間違ってますから
その考え方をやめなさいと言っても
絶対あなたの考えは聞きませんと
私はそう決めたんだからこうやっちゃいます
言ったらこちらも気持ち悪くなるでしょ
なんだこの人はこんな間違ってる考えで
それなのに頑固で じゃあ勝手にしなさいと思うこと自体も結局喧嘩なんですね
だから頑固さも喧嘩を招く
まあそういう 6つの性格
覚えておいた方が まあなんとか役に立つかもしれませんね
最終的に言えるのは このなぜ我々は水と牛乳のように溶けないかというと
我々は自分の主観にものすごく執着しているんですね
自分の主観というものに
私は見たもの 私は見たもの
聞いたもの 考えたもの
それは正しくて それは私であってというふうに思っているんですね
仏教から言うのは 私は見たんだからって
それは正しいということは言いにくい
私は聞いたんだからって
それは正しいということは言いにくいんです
そこは瞑想の世界ではっきり説明しますよ
例えば 私はいつも出す例
バラの花 1本見て持ってきて
ああ これは綺麗ですよというのは
これは私の主観であって
故に絶対的にバラの花というのは綺麗なものだよということはおかしいんです
人が描く絵なんか見たら
まあただ無差別に無茶苦茶あっちこっちペンキ塗ってることだけでしょうに
そこを見ると我々には美しい絵だと映るんです
だからそのもの自体が綺麗ということは別な話なんです
私は蕎麦を大好きですよと言うんだからといって
人類みんな蕎麦が好まなくてはならないと
蕎麦っていうのは客観的な美味しいものだというのはおかしいんです
だから私が見る聞くことっていうのは
私の主観であって それにとらわれてはいけませんということなんです
その主観は一つの幻覚なんですね
だからこの幻覚はどんな生命も作るんです
瞑想して悟らない限りは
瞑想して悟っても 幻覚破るのはほんの瞬間だけなんです
それからまた一般の人間として生きていなくちゃいけないんだから
また幻覚機能を取り戻してもらうんです
だから瞑想をもってこちらにあるバラの花は綺麗か綺麗じゃないか
バラか もうもうそれは蛇か
どっちかも判断しない場合はもう人間と喋れなくなるでしょうに
ですから 一旦悟ってからまた普通の幻覚の世界に戻るんだけど
その人は執着はしない
まあ私にはバラの花で見えるんだと
あなたにバラの花に見えるんですか？そうですか
じゃあ分かった それで終わっちゃうんです
それで私はうどん大好き
うどんこそ美味しいですよと
隣の人はいい ラーメンこそ美味しいですよ
と言ったら喧嘩になるでしょうね
向こうの人はあんたおかしいんだと
頑固だと ラーメン食べてみなさいと
その方が美味しいよと
それで喧嘩になりますね
それで悟りの境地から見れば
私にとっては何か美味しく感じますけど
あんたにラーメン美味しい感じますか？そう
なるほど それだけのこと
それで事実を認めるだけのこと
故にこれこそということはないんですね
ですから この主観ですね
問題は 主観はどれどれぐらい厳密に考えてほしいかというと
この例をよく覚えておいてください
バラの花は綺麗ですよということは主観なんです
事実ではないんです バラという言葉も主観であって
だから我々は見て聞いて感じて
頭の中で作る概念 それは私だけの世界であって
万人に共通している知識ではないんですね
そういうことで 人間というのはおかしいことに一番喧嘩作るのはこの概念の喧嘩
意見の喧嘩でほとんどの喧嘩が起こるんです
例えば白人が優れているんだと優越感が出てきて
大勢の人を殺されたでしょうに
黒人は奴隷までにしたでしょうに
人間を 人間の奴隷にまでして
また慈悲の教えもまた教えようとしている
だからあれは一つの概念でしょうに
日本人も日本人が絶対世界一偉いと思ってみてください
その日からもう不幸になっちゃうんです
もうどちらからでも叩かれるんですよ
だからこの何か主観作っちゃったら
概念作ったら まあ我々それまあそれ言ってしまっちゃうんですよ
例えばやっぱり世の中にいろいろ言語ありますけど
やっぱり日本語は素晴らしいんですよとかね
つい言っちゃいますけど
この迂闊に でも迂闊に言ったっても
それは別にどうしたことないんだけど
本気では思ってほしくないんです
そうすると大変な不幸になるんです
特にこの我々勉強するもの
学問 すべての知識 喧嘩の元なんです
戦争の元なんです まあこの医学の世界にしたっても
いろいろ知識で喧嘩したりするでしょうね
最終的には人を死ぬところまで行ってしまっちゃうし
政治学的な考えちゃうと
共産主義と何とか主義があったりして
どこまで人を死んだんですかね
ただの意見でしょ あれは
共産主義的な経済活動はいいやと
こちらもただの意見ですよ
資本主義的な考え方はいいやと
どちらでも間違ってるでしょ
はっきり言えば 資本主義で人は幸せになりませんし
共産主義でも人は幸せにならなかったし
でも人間でのそれによって殺し合いやってる
北朝鮮の問題もそういうことでしょうに
偉大なる神様はなんとか金
何でしたっけ？金日成だと思ってみんなに神様にしてしまって
暗示かけられたって ただのもう一人のバカマンでしょう
別に大したことはないんでしょうに
善人だったらそれまで
もう人の権利まで奪って独裁者にならないでしょうに
だからそれだけでも善人でないってことわかるんだけど
善人っていうのは自分の力があったら頑張って
まあ私はもうダメやから誰かがやってくださいと
能力ある人にバトンタッチするでしょうに
死んでも神様として信仰してほしいと
中国だったら何とかもうないかな
マオツェドンとかね 日本
ソ連もレニンを神様にしたかったんだけど
我々もう終わっちゃったんだけどね
だからまあそうやってただの意見でしょ
そんなものに なんで人類を不幸にするんですか
ですから 最終的に言えるのは
主観というのは主観であること
それは万人の知識ではないんだと
たとえ私は哲学者であろうか
世界にありったけの知識を頭の中に積み込もうか
一旦私のあの頭の中に入っちゃったら
もう主観なんです 最後にこの例で
終わります ご飯というのは美味しいものでね
見たらよだれも出ます
もう夏だから 例えばあのうなぎ
なんでしたっけ？まあ
うなぎの弁当でも何かあるとする
見たら美味しいなとと思う
そこで誰も手を触れない場合はみんな美味しいと
ちょっとよだれも出ると
そこで一人の人がそれを持って自分で箸を入れる
それから誰も食べないんです
だから自分のものになったら
それは主観であって 万人のものじゃないんです
それで体の中に入って口の中に入っちゃったら
まあ一旦 例えば自分が食べたものは自分の子供は残しても食べるかもしれませんし
あるいは子供は半分わざと食べちゃっても
自分が残り食べる場合もあるんだけど
自分の口に入っちゃったら
もう食べるところか見たくもないでしょ
気持ち悪くて すごい高価なうなぎかもしれませんよ
一旦口に入ったら ですから
世の中にあるすべての知識っていうのは
得てない時は立派かもしれません
一旦自分が得たところで
あれはあくまでも主観であって
口に入ったうなぎ弁当の一口だと思ってください
それでもって喧嘩してはいけませんと
だからこの説法する時でも主観で説法してはいけません
だから私も仏教は一応理解しているつもりなんですけど
私は理解しているものはそのまま言っちゃうと何か吐いてるような感じなんですね
やっぱり客観的な知識を
お釈迦様の知識を伝えてあげなくちゃいけないんですね
まあそういうことで どんな概念にも
どんな主観にも 自分の意見には執着しないことで
心の中からすべての競争が
争いが消えていって 完璧
完璧な平和というものが成り立ちます
では どうもありがとうございました